madam speaker i yield one minute to the
distinguished speaker of the house
the gentlelady from california ms pelosi
the gentlewoman from california
is yielded one minute thank you madam
speaker i thank the gentleman for
yielding and for his leadership
madam speaker and his annual address to
our predecessors
in congress in 1862
president abraham lincoln spoke at the
duty of the patriot
in an hour of decisive crisis for the
american people
fellow citizens he said we cannot escape
history
we will be remembered in spite of
ourselves
no personal significance or
insignificance
can spare uh one or another of us
the fiery trial through which we pass
will light us down in honor
or dishonor to the lattice latest
generation
we even we here he said
hold the power and bear the
responsibility
in the bible saint paul wrote think on
these things
we must think on what lincoln told
us we even here even us here
hold the power and bear the
responsibility
we you and i hold and trust
the power that derives most directly
from the people of the united states
and we bear the responsibility to fill
that oath
that we all swear before god and before
one another
the oath to defend the constitution
against all enemies
foreign and domestic so help us god
we know that we face enemies of the
constitution we know
we experienced the insurrection that
violated the sanctity of the people's
capital
and attempted to overturn the duly
recorded will
of the american people and we know that
the president
of the united states incited this
insurrection
this armed rebellion against our common
country
he must go he is a clear and present
danger
to the nation that we all love
since the presidential election in
november an election the president
lost he has repeatedly held
about the uh lied about the outcome so
self-serving doubt
about democracy and unconstitutionally
sought to influence
state officials to repeal reality
and then came that day of fire we all
experienced
the president must be impeached and i
believe the president must be convicted
by the senate
a constitutional remedy that will ensure
that the republic will be safe from this
man
who was so resolutely determined to tear
down the things that we hold dear
and that hold us together it gives me no
pleasure
to say this it breaks my heart it should
break your heart
should break all of our hearts for your
presence in this hollow chamber
is testament to your love for our
country
for america and to your faith in the
work
of our founders to create a more perfect
union
those insurrectionists were not patriots
they were not part of a political base
to be catered to and managed
they were domestic terrorists and
justice
must prevail but they did not appear out
of a vacuum
they were sent here sent here by the
president with words
such as a cry to fight like hell
words matter truth matters
accountability matters in his public
expectations to him the president saw
the insurrectionist
not as the face the foes of freedom as
they are
but as a means to a terrible goal the
goal of his personally
clinging to power the goal of thwarting
the will of the people
the goal of ending in a fiery and bloody
clash nearly two and a half centuries
of our democracy this is not theoretical
and this is not motivated by
partisanship i stand before you today as
an
officer of the constitution a speaker of
the house of representatives
i stand before you as a wife a mother a
grandmother
a daughter a daughter whose father
proudly
served in this congress thomas
d'alessandro jr from maryland
one of the first italian americans to
serve in the congress
and i stand here before you today as a
noblest of things
a citizen of the united states of
america
with my voice and my vote with a plea to
all of you
democrats and republicans i ask you to
search your souls
and answer these questions
is the president's war on democracy in
keeping with the constitution
were his words and in insurrectionary
mob a high crime and misdemeanor
do we not have the duty to our oath to
do all we constitutionally can to
protect our nation
and our democracy from the appetites and
ambitions
of a man who has self-evidently
demonstrated that he is a vital threat
to liberty to self-government and to the
rule of law
our country is divided we all know that
there are lies abroad in the land spread
by a desperate president
who feels his power slipping away
we know that too but i know this as well
that we here in this house have a sacred
obligation
to stand for truth to stand
up for the constitution to stand as
guardians of the republic
in a speech he was prepared to give in
dallas on friday november 22nd
1963 president john f
kennedy was to say we in this country
and this generation are by destiny
rather than choice
the watchmen on the walls of world
freedom
we ask therefore that we may be worthy
of our power and responsibility
that we may be worthy president kennedy
was assassinated before he could deliver
those words to the nation
but they resonate more even now
in our time in this place
let us be worthy of our power and
responsibility
that what lincoln thought was the
world's last
best hope the united states of america
may long survive my fellow members my
fellow americans
we cannot escape history let us embrace
our duty fulfill
our oath and honor the trust of our
nation
and we pray that god will continue to
bless
america i thank you madam speaker and
you'll bet